foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
the taliban have been taking over
territories
slowly and deliberately for many months
and even a period of years
you had the taliban skillfully picking
off
provinces where they reckoned they could
suborn the governor otherwise get the
warlords and the elite on side
afghanistan is spinning out of control
i saw
20 years of engagement in afghanistan be
more or less on the mind
in a few weeks
[Music]
well everyone was surprised by the speed
at which the 34 provincial capitals fell
to the taliban
we have noted with great concern uh the
speed with which they have been moving
and the lack of resistance that they
have faced
and then you have president ashraf ghani
quitting his post
and once you know your
commander-in-chief
flees
that's it
it's all over
i'm in shock
just i'm thinking what's happening
and why
[Music]
it was becoming
clearer and clearer that something is
going to be happening
and that something is not going to be
anything else but
the fall of afghanistan
what we did see in the collapse
was more of a political collapse than it
was in military collapse and that was
not foreseen
did you expect kabul to fall as quickly
as it did no no and i don't know anybody
who did
[Music]
we knew the taliban were coming we just
didn't know when
cities and towns kept falling but on the
face of it kabul seems pretty much as
normal
the usual traffic clogs up huge sections
of the city closed and barricaded from
potential suicide attacks
but this isn't normal
it's very tense
high numbers of people are making their
way to the capital
it's an early indicator that things are
already going badly wrong
[Music]
they flood into the city's parks
carrying whatever possessions they can
they huddle together trying to find
safety
the lightning offensive of the taliban
on cities in the north east south and
west of the country is simply
overwhelming the army and the government
we met farida kurasani
her husband and brother both police
officers were killed by the taliban in
kunduz
she's escaped her kabul with her two
children
she has nothing now
do you think the americans leaving has
caused this problem
foreign
so taliban have taken logar province its
outer borders are only about 37 miles
down the road behind me and it feels now
that the fall of kabul is inevitable so
the city is now very much divided
between those who can leave or hope they
can leave and those who know they simply
can't
we find some of them crowded around
computers manned by experts
groups of men struggling to fill out the
application forms for immigration visas
security guards translators a whole
array of jobs
their visas the ones they're applying
for is their only passage to safety
but the process has been slow and it's
becoming more and more obvious that time
is running out
ali has worked as a special forces
translator since 2011
he still doesn't have permission to
travel
it is our turn
to be helped
we helped them you know we saved their
lives
we were the people who communicate with
two cultures
otherwise without
interpreters they did nothing
the taliban though really are getting
close uh to the city now some say it's
only relatively speaking seven ten miles
away maybe uh slightly further
um the speed of the taliban takeover has
of course surprised many
the air of uncertainty in kabul grows by
the minute
at the airport british and american
military and crucially their equipment
begin arriving
transporter planes landing and taxiing
on the runways
by sunday morning we know the taliban
are just a few miles away
helicopter gunships appear over our
heads and over the presidential palace
and government buildings in the center
of the city
for hours they circle above but there is
nothing they can do to stop the takeover
of the capital now
occasional gunfire rips through the air
throughout the day chinook helicopters
ferry united states embassy staff to the
international airport
road moves are now deemed too dangerous
[Music]
near the presidential palace i watch as
the taliban enter the very heart of this
country's government and i'll be honest
i was surprised hospital care would
continue so you're going to hear a lot
of shouting uh
coming down the road behind me in fact
it is a
i think it's a procession of uh of the
taliban uh yes it is there's the white
flag
and uh they're coming down uh the street
uh just next to us they're in their
xiaowakamis they're led by a white flag
the world is following events in
afghanistan with a heavy heart
and deep disquiet about what lies ahead
they came in the palace it's a shocking
it's just shocking really
how did you feel when you saw those oh
no really
i just asked my tv i didn't watch
i can't see my country
or that kind of culture
no
oh
[Music]
the flight of the senior government
officials and the evacuation of the
embassies
seem to be the things that precipitate
this panic
of people flocking to the airports
well we were caught up with our pants in
half mast
i don't think there's any other way
around this
that's the most
unbelievable unbelievable scene of my
life
[Music]
and every single day because of this
chaos and because of this rush of people
a lot of people in afghanistan that they
had the possibility when the paper works
and and some of them were their visas
and everything they could not get out of
the country and they're still stuck
[Music]
the people they left afghanistan
there are ministers they are ngo charity
directors
they are judges yeah they are the
doctors
they don't wanted to leave but the
situation forced them to leave
the airport scenes epitomize the horror
of the whole thing
[Music]
[Applause]
people are just leaving everything
behind but what they could carry on
their backs
i would say i was shocked and sorry
shocked because i had never
expected to experience
such
and disorderly withdrawal
[Music]
people clinging to the bottom of the
plane is the image that really sticks
sticks with me people being so desperate
that they're flocking
to
the airplanes and trying to hold on and
get into wheel wells and
um
you know somehow hang on to an airplane
that's that's that's departing
[Music]
i mean it just a desperate image which
shows
unfortunately just exposes
how much at fault we are
how much to blame we are for this
catastrophe
[Music]
like
as every day passes the relief operation
is getting more and more urgent and
[Music]
the desperate military are now trying to
move thousands of people out of
afghanistan in just days before the
august 31st deadline
on the airport road a makeshift
barricade separates two armies who
fought for 20 years
this is a humanitarian effort but it's
being done by the military because we're
effectively in a war zone and what's
incredible
just one step away
there's a taliban right next to the
british
forces who are trying to assess the
people who are trying to get onto these
relief flights
as one of the soldiers said to me they
could mess this up by just sending a
thousand blokes down the road at the
moment
they're cooperating and uh they're
actually keeping things calm
the taliban are a menacing presence
although they are trying to assist in
their own way
along the road they're controlling the
crowds of people trying to reach the
british position
[Music]
it looks like chaos but there is a
method here
the soldiers call out for interpreters
as different nationalities arrived
their paperwork is checked and if they
pass muster they're directed to the
entry gate to be processed
but many do not qualify
the soldiers absolutely hate doing this
but without the paperwork they have to
turn people away
it's distressing for everyone
we watch as terrified families men women
and large numbers of children are sent
back
back into afghanistan
back towards the taliban
[Music]
inside the british cordon we meet fatima
her husband joined the taliban and took
to beating her
she and her four-year-old have nothing
but a united nations letter identifying
them as victims afghanistan is told upon
thought about history it's my husband
my husband is a
tourist
america canada
um
and just my so you and your daughter
you'll go anywhere
the soldiers have a reasonable degree of
latitude in their decision making so
major steve white decides to enter her
into the system with no guarantees it
will work out
it's quite simply an act of human
kindness in all this mayhem
[Music]
fatima makes it inside
you're safe
when we later learn she made it to
germany
major white may have saved their lives
he's certainly given them a chance for a
better one
these soldiers are involved in a mission
as diametrically opposed to anything
they could ever have expected in
afghanistan
[Music]
the truth is the taliban have won
and every day here is getting stranger
and stranger
amongst the crowd british passport
holders waved to us unable to come
forward told to stay where they are
there are lots of british nationals and
europeans as well waiting for their turn
inside well the crowds have got so close
now
um that the um soldiers have to form
basically a square
um to get from one compound to another
they're taking out civilians and uh
they've trying to keep everyone calm
those of them have got
the right to come inside but at the
moment they can't very very tense here
very very tense because these people are
desperate
in single file the evacuees headed to
the united states are brought out of the
british camp and directed to the
americans
these are whole families attempting to
escape the new taliban emirate of
afghanistan
there are always so many children
hopefully too young to know what on
earth is going on
from the compound a helicopter lifts off
ferrying the refugees to the military
airport
this day is calm
it's never going to be this con again
why did the u.s and the allied borders
leave afghanistan
well i think president biden laid it out
pretty clearly
he has reminded americans virtually
every time
he's addressed this issue he's reminded
us of where this started which is with
the narrow objective to bring al qaeda
to justice and make ourselves more safe
the reason we went into afghanistan was
very straightforward
the afghan
war was a war of necessity
in the wake of 9 11 20 years ago we went
there to ensure we weren't about to be
attacked again
we didn't know much about al qaeda and
we certainly didn't know
that the only attacks that we were about
to about to suffer were the ones the
previous day on 9 11.
we also considered it part of our
territorial
security to prevent afghanistan from
once again
becoming a safe haven for
terrorists
taliban government had been presented
with an ultimatum
to give access to western forces
to the al qaeda bases
the taliban government refused to give
that access
so the objective was the removal of the
taliban government and then the
installation
of an alternative government
it took almost no time
if we deliver to the afghan people what
we promised this will be a great day if
we don't deliver
this will go into oblivion after that we
had a responsibility to rebuild an
afghan society from
scratch
we spent
from 2001 until 2014
to do that
so there was this urgency in the early
days
to address the immediate threat uh which
emanated out of uh out of afghanistan
if you're not going to afghanistan
um there would have been as it were the
equivalent to more 911s
especially i think after bin laden was
brought to justice in 2011
american public support for the war has
waned
our troops will continue coming home at
a steady pace as afghan security forces
move into the lead
our mission will change from combat to
support
america
it is time to focus on nation building
here at home
[Music]
the strategic failure
of the united states lies in president
obama 20 2011 announcing arbitrarily
that he wanted to reduce troops
dramatically by 2014 taraban fought fine
then
president trump who claimed to be the
dealmaker of the century
holding direct discussions with the
taliban
without any of the other parties present
including the afghan government we've
had
very successful negotiations we think
they'll be successful in the end
the other side's tired
of war everybody's tired of war
[Music]
that was a big
mistake i would call it a catastrophe
everything was put on a silver platter
and was given to them
with a pat on the back and saying that
you know you are the winners
and i don't understand it to the united
states how did you accept i think i told
the americans what they hated the most
was to lose
the taliban have every incentive to
wait for us to leave because their
leverage is going to be higher and the
afghan government had every incentive to
try to
undermine the talks in hopes that we
would stay
it is a big mistake
to reveal to your opponents on which
date you will withdraw
never ever tell your enemy when you will
withdraw
mr trump who claimed to be this great
deal maker
had gone into the negotiations the
dealers dished out the cards
and trump looked at his cards and said
oh well i've got a couple of laces here
would he like them
and gave them away and and the taliban
must have thought
as it were
it's christmas
we're ending america's longest war
your own intelligence community has
assessed that the afghan government will
likely collapse that's not true
[Music]
you have the afghan troops have 300 000
well-equipped as well as equipped as any
army in the world
and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
[Music]
it's a silly question do i trust the
taliban no
trump made the decision to withdraw on
may 1st
he then presented essentially president
biden a binary choice between abiding by
that agreement
or abrogating it do you think his
options were as simple as that one or
the other
no i don't agree
i think the right approach would have
been
to say okay we will not
feel obliged to
comply with that date
the withdrawal will be condition based
thank you all so very much
taliban officials on the withdrawal
they've been in korea south korea for 70
years when there is a possibility
of war so to just say 20 years is too
long call it a forever war bit of a
bumper sticker and feel you've got to
end it i'm afraid that's part and parcel
of the problem
it didn't have to be like this
but once the americans
without consultation within the alliance
decided to withdraw their troops
the other
coalition partners had to do exactly the
same because without the americans
we can't do anything
we left afghanistan when we did
because the americans said so that's a
blunt truth
i don't think there's
anybody certainly not
in the british military you british
defense secretary for a moment thinks
this is the right decision to make
70
of americans support the president's
decision now the implementation
is still in question
[Music]
it's just horrendous
the taliban are hitting people and the
paratroopers have no choice but to hold
the line
the road to safety is packed thousands
upon thousands
once again it's up to a small contingent
of soldiers to deal with this mess
it's hard to put into words how
desperate it is and depressingly most of
these people won't make it through
i'm sorry
british elders spot a baby in danger and
they take control with her family in tow
they make their way to the compound
these are combat soldiers remember but
they also care what's happening here
sometimes just sometimes you see joy
breaking out
but where he'd a former british
interpreter
he and his family are going to the uk
it's been agreed
this is a very
a very happy day in my life
yeah have you got family in britain no
no no no so you're the first yeah yeah
i'm going to go to britain that's my
first trip to britain and so you're
waiting just to get processed was it
scary outside yes it was very scary it
was very hard to find outside like a
zombie
like a zombie so zombieland
what are you most excited about in
britain
to educate my family and my children to
uh to britain
and in britain and become an engineer
and doctor in britain
[Music]
for the hopeful
it's a sort of purgatory
day night it makes no difference
in their thousands they just have to
wait sleeping rough hoping for news
hoping they can get into the system
at night we walk past thousands of
children parents grandparents grabbing
sleep or basically passing out from
exhaustion
the soldiers do their best to help but
there's no food out here than little
water
it is thankfully though cooler at night
when the sun comes up the true horror of
the conditions they're living in is
obvious
the hysteria envelops the crowd from
nowhere
the problem now is not
trying to control the crowds per se it's
the fact that at the front people are
just getting crushed
shocked soldiers spray the crowd with a
hose anything to cool them down
[Applause]
crushed dehydrated and terrified
men
women
and lots of children
is this a stabilized withdrawal from
afghanistan
it looks like death to me
in the mayhem units rush through the
crowds to shore up weak points in the
evacuation center
they're working flat out trying to stem
the tide of an unfolding disaster
thousands of afghans who are coming who
have no right to come here but they're
coming anyway and they they can't just
leave them to get crushed in and the
heat is terrible there's lots of
children so they have to have a sort of
secondary
barrier where people who may have never
get in properly
are at least safe for the time being
it's uh
it just seems to go for better worse
here and there's
i don't know
almost speechless as to what they're
going to do about it
american soldiers pulling children whole
families from the pens they're being
kept behind for processing
these people fear their dreams of a
flight out are ebbing away as each day
passes
soldiers are firing near they fear
they're losing control
out here pain and compassion meet every
minute of every day
if it's to be turned around
they'll need more time
but time is running out
i stand squarely behind my decision
[Music]
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we plan for every contingency but
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated
so what's happened
the taliban used the
17 months between the signing of the us
taliban agreement
and august 2021 very wisely negotiating
these surrenders or capitulations
throughout the country and they were
universally successful
[Music]
while the afghan government just simply
buried its head in the sand and didn't
prepare
its defensive positions didn't prepare
its units
as we built the afghan forces
we tended to focus on the inputs into
that force which could be quantified and
we didn't appreciate enough
the fragility of those moral factors
[Music]
we withdrew our technical
training mentoring and moral support and
they felt abandoned and the fear of the
taliban took over
if we had stood with them they would
have continued to fight
the main conclusion is
you
must
never
ever
go behind the back of your friends
and that's exactly what has happened
here
[Music]
[Music]
we're into the final days of the airlift
now
[Music]
british evacuees are loaded into trucks
and vans
[Music]
their journey started days ago but this
is perhaps the beginning of the most
important drive they'll ever take
this is the convoy that takes the latest
evacuees to the hamid karzai
international airport to board a
military flight to the uk
[Music]
they go through the gates of the
compound where their status has been
checked and confirmed
and back into the territory of the
taliban
and the wilderness of the thousands
waiting for news
to the writer sewage canal
a holding pen for people who might have
the right paperwork
thousands upon thousands trapped
behind them the taliban
in front soldiers deciding who stays and
who goes
nobody planned this
it's just how it is
the hours are counting down and they
know it
there are no good options left to them
such as the desperation to be heard by
the soldiers the would-be evacuees are
standing up to their knees in a
sewage-filled canal
stench is indescribable
[Music]
some have been here for days
it's hot there's little water and hardly
any food
these are mostly american soldiers
marines and when they can identify
people with the right papers for travel
they pull them out of the canal
they emerged dripping wet but relieved
the fact is that
when the withdrawal happens
it's always going to be difficult
because they can't keep working the
soldiers can't keep working up until the
last minute
they have to start withdrawing in the
days leading up to their departure
how they're going to deal with these
people when that happens we just don't
know
[Music]
the security threats grow every day
everyone knows it
the soldiers
the evacuees even us
we talk about it constantly
[Music]
we've been fighting to stay for days
to be here to document the final
withdrawal of the troops after a 20-year
campaign
[Music]
but we've lost that battle and now we
have to leave
we load up and move out
we feel guilty for leaving
an easy exit for a group of journalists
guaranteed safety by our soldiers and
our governments
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
a tough day
this evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
took the lives of american service
members
standing guard at the airport
wounded several others seriously
the attack
was
absolutely horrifying i mean really
horrifying
it was an extraordinarily unsafe place
to be
but afghans saw this as their last
chance to get out of the country
[Music]
joe biden may be able to say to the
american people well we've removed all
these um
all our troops you know they're back
home safely but
what the indelible
images the american people have
is actually of a number of american
service personnel being brought home in
bodybags
because they got blown up by even worse
insurgents
than the taliban
the taliban are not allied with these
people who set off the bomb but there's
absolutely no doubt these people are
able to operate with impunity inside a
taliban controlled afghanistan
[Music]
the americans our western forces
including british forces have left
there will be a taliban
that government
if the taliban
are saying that they want
diplomatic relations
with the west
we should do so
[Music]
the reality of engagement with the
taliban is that
you have to be very realistic about who
they are
to understand that they have a
horrifying record
but what alternative do we have
there is no leverage left over the
taliban we've just handed the entire
country to them
president biden said that he'll be going
after these isis k terrorists how can
you do that with the withdrawing troop
presence well
he could do it from over the horizon um
and so
both the intelligence which will cue or
trigger a strike
against the islamic state as well as the
strike capabilities themselves
can be
although imperfectly
can be based outside of afghanistan
this is going to be hard
but not impossible
president biden keeps saying there's no
terrorist threat
coming from afghanistan i think
his idea that he's ended the global war
on terror it's crazy
he's probably given another 10 years to
these types of terrorist threats totally
unnecessarily he's given a huge morale
victory
to jihadists around the world
if you get the situation where the
international community turns its back
on afghanistan
afghanistan begins to devolve into
warring fiefdoms and a new civil war
then that's the scenario where al qaeda
is going to
to come back where islamic state is
going to get more of her presence that's
this area where you're going to get your
most acute international terrorist
threat
well i want to show you something mr
president afghanistan is going to change
so much
in this action of yours
that you will be amazed
what happened
you know the backlash the result in what
is going to happen in the world
because of this decision will be so
phenomenal
that the world is going to say wow
what the heck did we do
for america just to remove itself
voluntarily
in such an humiliating way
is to provide a strategic victory
for
the west's adversaries the chinese the
russians the iranians are absolutely
delighted about this and they're telling
their peoples yeah we told you so
this is this is what american power does
one
lesson should be learned from this
namely
when the united states
with a draw
then
they would leave behind
a vacuum
and that void will be filled by the bad
guys and that's exactly what we have
seen demonstrated in afghanistan
[Music]
the c-17 we board is absolutely huge
so we're uh we're finally on the plane i
mean it's absolutely full i can't
believe my eye
it's huge but there's over 400 people in
here
the evacuees here are fortunate to get
out of afghanistan for certain
but their lives have been altered
immeasurably in just over a week
a bag each is all they have left of
their lives
it's
[Music]
quite an experience really
i'm really sad overwhelmingly sad
actually
it's all the people
that are still there
waiting
is one of the last few flights going now
there ain't many left
just before takeoff the lights turn
green
and that is it
[Music]
in the green light we watch families sit
and talk
their children restless at times or
asleep
a chatter mixed with anxiety
i can't get the faces of those left
behind out of my mind standing in the
sewage canal pleading for help
i never will
[Music]
oh
[Music]
lovers
[Music]
you